die bundestagswahl ist nun zwei tage her
vor gut 50 stunden haben die wahllokale
geschlossen und dass wir danach gesehen
haben vor allem bei der union das war
ein ganz merkwürdiges theaterstück das
hat mich eigentlich erinnert an gerhard
schröder 2005 auch erinnerung an donald
trump 2020 wurden wach und
kanzlerkandidat armin laschet war doch
wirklich der meinung er habe einen
regierungsauftrag bekommen obwohl seine
union das schlechteste wahlergebnis
aller zeiten eingefahren hat obwohl die
union ein viertel ihrer stimmen zum
ohnehin schon schlechten ergebnis von
217 eingebüßt hat bergo armin laschet
will weiter kanzler werden aber die
vergangenen 50 stunden haben gezeigt
dass selbst der bratwurst packt mit
markus söder der freitag vor gut einer
woche hatte vor zehn tagen geschlossen
wurde mittlerweile überhaupt nichts mehr
wert ist armin laschet steht allein im
wind es gab heute
rücktrittsforderungen deswegen es ist
glaube ich das deutlich jetzt auch
einmal zu sagen armin laschet die zeit
ist vorbei wolfgang schäuble würde sagen
ja und es wird zeit für armin laschet zu
erkennen was der bürgerwille ist aber
auch was ein großer teil in seiner
eigenen cdu mittlerweile denkt er hat
das vertrauen verspielt er hat das
gespür für bürger aber auch für viele in
der eigenen partei komplett verloren und
deswegen ist es zeit den weg frei zu
machen für einen echten neuanfang
ja ich habe den ziemlich laut dem
fasziniert und frage mich aber für was
für neuanfang weil die menschen die dann
sozusagen dran wären in die ämter der
macht denn die mächtigsten untersuchung
sind ja nicht etwa eine frischzellenkur
sondern die üblichen verdächtigen in
anführungszeichen ich glaube dass armin
laschet sich so schwer damit tut den weg
frei zu machen weil er auch spürt dass
es gar kein aufbruchsignal dann gibt
sondern die pöstchen man halt einfach
anders verteilt und jetzt kommt das
entscheidende für ihn ist dann alles wie
du gesagt hast over weil es mir schwer
tue mir vorzustellen dass der große
verlierer armin laschet dann eine große
politische zukunft in nordrhein
westfalen hat aber da schaue ich schon
den landeswahlen darunter alle hat sich
armin laschet festgelegt china hat sich
anna schildt festgelegt sein weg geht
nach berlin ob ins kanzleramt oder auf
einen abgeordneten stuhl ist ja im
moment noch völlig offen kanzleramt oder
hinterbank das ist das was er jetzt vor
der wahl steht ja eigentlich jetzt ja es
gibt auch noch andere möglichkeiten
fraktionsvorstand stellvertreter oder
wie ich der ausschussvorsitzender aber
sie haben schon recht kein vergleich mit
dem amt
ministerpräsident in nordrhein-westfalen
ich weiß aber aus der heimat dass man
dort schon überlegt wer könnte denn
jetzt spitzenkandidat werden der
landtagswahl ist ja im frühjahr 22 das
kommt und dann also mein favorit über
hendrik wüst aber dann wird es auch
einen generationenwechsel geben der ist
ja nun deutlich haben dort gibt's denn
dann und ja ich sage gibt es den dann
wirklich das wäre ich glaube auch die
idee die sehnsucht nach der rückkehr
würde sich in grenzen halten weil dann
das gefühl aufgeben die träume in berlin
sind nicht wahr geworden dann doch
wieder zurück in die staatskanzlei nach
düsseldorf ich glaube dass man
feststellen kann auch nach diesem
ergebnis für die union und nach den
vorangegangenen monaten
sie sind zwar aus dem landesverband von
armin laschet haben ja auch unterstützt
aber müssen doch wahrscheinlich auch
verstehen wir brauchen eigentlich in der
deutschen politik mehr amerika also
dieses thema vorwahlen dass sich mehrere
kandidaten auch in der cdu
beispielsweise raider union in der spd
vorstellung sage ich möchte laufen und
das aber auch ganz normale bürger keine
parteisoldaten sondern ganz normale
bürger die chance haben zu sagen also
wenn der wolfgang bosbach antreten würde
für das bundeskanzleramt bei der cdu/csu
dann würde ich ihn unterstützen deswegen
würde ich bei ihnen sagen machen sie da
bundesbürger können abstand aber warum
bestimmte nur ein mini zirkel eigentlich
wer überhaupt zur wahl an der stelle der
pause ist natürlich komplizierter war es
ja zwei parteien sind ich kann in seinem
kompliziert ist es ist ja doch ist eine
sehr selbstbewusste partei aber wir
haben das alles schon mal gehabt wir
haben die roadshow der spd
parteivorsitzenden gehabt und wer ist es
geworden olaf scholz dinger nicht als
partei vor sich
ein punkt ist ein anderer mann punkt ist
nicht dass die spd mitglieder über ihren
spd kandidaten abstimmen sondern der
punkt ist dass die bundesbürger
abstimmen können wen würden sie denn
eigentlich bei der spd gut finden wenn
so ist es amerika ja auch da können sie
als republikaner auch bei den klaren
wohin so und das ist doch der punkt und
dann können ganz normal rüber sagt
wolfgang bosbach super aber da hätte sie
plötzlich wieder chancen
bisher ist aber deswegen ein schräges
beispiel weil wir ein anderes problem
hatten nicht das es ging doch in der
union im kern um verhindern zuerst mal
sollte friedrich merz verhindert werden
dann wurde es annegret kramp karrenbauer
dann sollte friedrich merz wieder
verhindert werden dann kam noch norbert
röttgen dazu am ende wurde ist armin
laschet und ganz zum schluss sollte
markus söder verhindert werden und
wieder wurde ist der armin laschet
deshalb fest in pointe und
das ist so verhindert die partei damit
kanzler
stellt euch märz war der favorit der
basis und nach allen umfragen mussten
wir markus söder ist der favorit des
publikums der bevölkerung aber der
cdu-bundesvorstand hat sich anders
entschieden und eins kann ich ihnen
sagen als sie ihren irrtum erkannten
verdoppelten sie ihre anstrengungen da
wird keiner sagen das war eine falsche
entscheidung wird mit anderen besser
abgeschnitten werden alle sagen das war
richtig aber war es daniela schuld von
wolfgang schäuble wir haben die spanne
these gehört ich gab letzte woche hat
einer unserer gäste sagt angela merkel
wollte markus söder und deswegen wurde
es armin laschet weil sie armin laschet
nicht wollte und der bundesvorstand sich
dann durchgesetzt hat dass ein bisschen
schlecht jedenfalls volker bouffier nach
halle wurde ja wohl aber wer nach an der
partei dass da unlogisch also wolfgang
schäuble und volker bouffier haben ein
solches gewicht im bundes natürlich nur
eine stimme aber ein solches gewicht vor
allen dingen wolfgang schäuble und er
hat zum schluss den ausschlag dafür
gegeben dass armin laschet wurde auch
mit dem argument die große stolze cdu
kann sich doch nicht
nominieren lassen vor allem von der von
der kleinen schwesterpartei csu daher
gab hat die csu noch die
wirklich ins politischen klein klein
gedacht wie es einmal sagen
klein-klein
ironie ich muss also ich weiß auch
wirklich nicht ab er dem armen land auch
nicht zu viel vom misserfolg der cdu
hier anders er war jetzt sicherlich kein
strahlender alles optimal oder von
anlagen kandidat ja aber ich glaube die
partei die probleme der partei gehen
schon tiefer als nur die nominierung von
armin laschet punkt eins und punkt zwei
weil es weil ihm jetzt auch jeder
kleinste fehltritt und manchmal dinge wo
ich denke das war vielleicht noch nicht
mal ein solcher im übermaß angelastet
wird also beispielsweise seine
äußerungen kurz nach der wahl dass auch
er anstreben würde eine regierung zu
bilden da wird sich zeigen ja wieso denn
nicht also also wieso sollte erst dann
nicht zumindest versuchen ja also dieser
ganze terminus
regierungsauftrag das ist ja letztlich
eine eine erfindung es gibt keinen
regierungsauftrag es gibt einfach ein
wahlergebnis mit dem kann man mehrheiten
bilden das kann die union mit fdp und
grünen zusammen genauso wie die spd ist
kann und dass er das jetzt weiterhin
versucht ist absolut nachvollziehbar und
ich weiß halt also zu sagen ich finde
ist breitet es sich da so ein bisschen
so einen defekt ismus in der union aus
der eigentlich vielleicht verfrüht ist
oder ihr schade aber wenn das verrückte
ist er hat sich schon vor der wahl
ausgebreitet das war für mich das
erschrecken wird also das sozusagen das
ist dieses gemeinsame ziel armin laschet
kanzler werden zu lassen gar nicht
wirklich fühlbar war sondern es ist
immer gesagt worden und dann kam es in
die kameras aus waren zum augenrollen ja
wir wissen schon der armin laschet und
das haben die schon komisch ich will
aber noch mal was anderes machen wir
sind jetzt auch in so einer polit polit
berlin raumschiff diskussion ich mache
mir so ein bisschen sorgen wie das alles
was jetzt in berlin stattfindet wieder
auf die bürger wirkt nämlich ich bin
nicht sicher ob es auf die wirkt das ist
jetzt das zähe ringen um eine
bundesregierung oder der kann
verschiedener einstellungen wer wer
vorne liegen soll sondern ich habe das
gefühl es ist eher das schauspiel das
bestätigt wie man sich berlin oft zu
unrecht aus der distanz vorstellen das
geht eigentlich nur um posten es geht
nur um freunde es geht nur um die banken
sitzen im bundestag zu verteidigen und
wenn man es verloren hat zu stänkern es
geht nur um
renten um abfindungen um ansprüche das
vermittelt sich mit jedem tag und die
person völlig zu unrecht an der sich das
fest macht und das kriegt er jetzt doch
noch ab sozusagen das armin laschet mit
diesem ich mache den weg nicht frei
irgendwie sehen sich glaube ich
das land nach einer befreiung machte
auch den weg frei sowie anfordert und
dann sollen die sich endlich
zusammenraufen und das machen und wenn
dann einer sagt ich hoffe dass bis
weihnachten der regierung gebildet ist
denn die haben wir ja nicht dabei ganz
kurz die haben wir schon 14 jahre habe
halt einmal kurz sagen da viele handy
alarm gehabt wir kommen alle anlagen und
jetzt haben wir dem brinkhaus alarm
bekomme gerade aufs ohr gesagt dass
ralph brinkhaus der
cdu/csu-fraktionsvorsitzende
wiedergewählt wurde für ein halbes jahr
das ist wichtig für alle die bereits
brinkhaus gar nicht kennen
möglicherweise ralph brinkhaus ist der
chef der cdu/csu-fraktion es gab ein
großes machtkampf darum darf er sich
heute turnusgemäß wieder wählen lassen
für ein jahr das wollte das system armin
laschet nicht genau das wollte armin
laschet verhindern und jetzt hat man
sich auf einen kompromiss geeinigt ein
halbes jahr ist jetzt reif brinkhaus
oder für ein halbes jahr erst mal
gewählt ganz frisch mir etwas über 170
stimmen also das war schon eine zu junge
union zeit so jetzt kommt offiziell
siebziger jahre das war ein ganz
wichtiger satz immer sachfragen sind
wichtiger als personalfragen die
wichtigste frage ist was wird aus mir
heraus jetzt hat man natürlich einen
großen unterschied ob man in der
opposition ist dann hast du einen
wirklich wichtigen posten zu vergeben
dass der fraktionsvorsitzende als erster
an antworten als stärkste
oppositionspartei auf die regierung oder
ob der in der regierung bist dann hast
du minister dann hast du
staatssekretärin es zu einem bataillon
vom beauftragten fällt alles weg
deswegen kann ich auch verstehen dass
armin laschet sagt wir sind das
empfindung sondierungsphase wir wissen
noch nicht wie es weitergeht wir wollen
dieses wichtige amt jetzt nicht für ein
jahr zementiert und ich wette ich wette
sollte es so kommen ich gebe ja immer
noch auf jamaika aber sollte es so
kommen dass die union in der opposition
ist dann wird es noch andere
mit allem respekt auch für die union die
ja ganz ganz viele verdienste um dieses
land auch hat was ist das jetzt für eine
lösung was ist das für eine lösung es
ist wieder das ist dass es lauwarmer
pudding den wir hier sehen es ist nicht
wir machen neuanfang es ist auch nicht
die lasche stellt sich hin was
eigentlich wollte ich werde
fraktionschef um die verhandlung für ein
jamaika-bündnis wasser ja immer noch
anstrebt von vorne wie so schön heißt
zuführen nein man einigt sich auch nicht
auf ralph brinkhaus wie es die sagten
gerade selbst die statuten vorsehen für
ein jahr gewählt und 30 dran er wird für
ein halbes jahr gewicht ist ein
klassischer ich möchte fast sagen merkel
kompromiss man laviert sich durch die
die verloren haben lavieren sich wieder
durch und die die jetzt jungen sind und
antreten wollen die kriegen doch keine
chance also es ist höher und klaus hat
es glaube ich gerade im regen schon für
die menschen die sich berlin nicht aus
der berliner perspektive anschauen
sondern aus der brandenburger der
bayerischen die wurden auch die politik
besuch wie sie glauben dass sie wäre so
wisst ihr ja
[Gelächter]
der verlierer in auftrag und da kann ich
noch sagen jetzt komme ich mit dem und
mit dem und ich will da irgendwann
werden jemals so dramatisch einbüßt da
hat er verloren das muss man akzeptieren
das ist guter stil
[Musik]